[Music]
are we rolling on everything already
test color
no i want to do that you got it go for
it
all right what's up guys mkbhd here and
welcome to another uh i guess a slightly
unusual video but so just to give a
little context on what's going on here
just shot a video with star talk and it
went pretty well you should go and check
it out i'll probably have a link in the
description below but i figured while
i'm here with neil and chuck i might as
well get a little interview in since
it's only fair since you did interview
me about two years ago
uh we should uh reverse roles a little
bit i'll talk to you for a little bit
good to see you again yeah good to see
you again too by the way
um you were cheering nicely you were
like 14 or something i was i was pretty
young and i feel like that was
definitely a big part of what we talked
about but
i've seen a lot since then and it's like
you were 12 years old
basically an infant but yeah so this is
this is gonna be fun i think the thing
that was on my mind just when i had the
opportunity to ask you anything uh is
just from a an astrophysicist
perspective i mean we look at the tech
that we have on the palm of our hands
every day and it's it's pretty sweet you
know new phones new tablets but a lot of
that comes from the higher end the the
military technology the space program
technology a lot of things eventually
trickle their way down into what we're
able to hold in our hands are there
things that you guys have seen or heard
of
that maybe we don't know about that's on
its way that might end up in our phones
or tablets or handheld someday i'm not
authorized to
if i tell you
uh why don't i
i have some ideas but i'm not very good
at predicting the future sure and i have
good evidence that i'm not good at
predicting the future and i've told this
many times chuck when i'm old enough to
remember star trek in first run okay my
parents did too
and so there's the warp drives and the
photon torpedoes and
and this machine we put in a card and
then
hot food comes out instantly this was an
extraordinary view of the future and i
said yeah yeah that's all going to
happen and there was one thing about
star trek that i could not imagine and
it it took the realism of star trek out
of it for me and that was the fact that
they could just walk up to a door and
the door would open i said how does the
door know it can't know that they're
there okay they're over here and now
they're there and it opens and for some
reason the warp drives and the photon
torpedoes and the transporters were all
believable to me but not the auto
opening door automatic doors is where
you drew the line i had to that i i was
i also this is all literally before any
automatic doors
okay so that's why i wouldn't trust my
sense of the future here but i do want
to give you an acute
appreciation for
how the past became the future
all right so let's go back a hundred
years the dawn of our understanding
of the atom now how does the atom work i
don't know let's probe it we start
probing it in the 1920s through particle
accelerators and experiments out of this
comes quantum physics
the quantum on top of that albert
einstein says hmm
using what we know about quantum physics
and using what we know about this kind
of physics i can put them together
calculate
i've come up with a new thing
that would occur in atoms it's called
the stimulated emission of radiation
okay
no one paid any attention to that paper
it was interesting it advanced quantum
physics but if you had lawmakers and
politicians and people saying why
doesn't that help me today why are you
doing research that has nothing to do
with anything put them around back then
they would be criticizing quantum
physics from beginning to end what a
waste of resources you're so smart why
are you wasting it on atoms it would
take 40 years
50 years
before
quantum physics would become the very
foundation of information technology
there is no creation storage or
retrieval of information
without an understanding of the quantum
not only that this obscure research
paper that einstein wrote on the
stimulated emission of radiation it
would that would take 40 years 40 years
later
the laser would be invented based on
that principle oh what do three of those
letters stand for the light
amplification
by the stimulated emission of radiation
was einstein thinking
bar codes that's why i got it
laser cosmetic peel
no
no
so
all i can tell you is
i don't know what the future will bring
but if you stop investing in basic
research today
you won't have a future so it's being
worked on today we should encourage it
to be worked on today and don't go up to
a scientist and say how does that relate
to me today and how is that
the only right answer is i have no idea
but evidence of the history of this
exercise tells us that one day it will
so there are things that are hugely
important to your life and your i mean
the collective you
that
no one knows about yet correct
correct
all that matters
if you're curious is that you're
exploring something you do not yet know
i'll give can i give another example i
would love it my are you my example's
okay yeah are they working on the show
yeah so far so good because i don't want
to be like i don't want to i'm just kind
of absorbing it so feel free to okay
whatever you got usually you do all the
talking a lot of times i do but that's
scripted that's a lot easier oh real
okay okay now i'm not scripted i'm just
i'm just blathering it works all right
my physics professor in college
his name was edward purcell
sounds like a nice guy nice
yeah it turns out he was a really nice
guy he did calculations that gave us
ways to measure the existence and the
depth and the composition of gas clouds
in space did very important research he
also discovered a phenome co-discovered
a phenomenon
where if you put an electromagnetic
field across
an atomic nucleus
okay
it will
actually change that field
according to the mass of the nucleus the
resonance between the light that passed
across it and the nucleus itself
okay
it was called
nuclear
magnetic resonance
got the nobel prize for that afterwards
a clever medical engineer said wait a
minute if you could put this field
across and know the mass of the nucleus
and i can differentiate this nucleus
from this nucleus i can make a machine
put you in the machine make images of
all your nuclei
and thus was born the magnetic resonance
imaging which used to have
and but it's one of the n words that
you're not supposed to use nuclear
it's you go into a machine that uses
nuclear magnetic resonance but the
hospitals figured nobody wants to go
into a machine that has nuclear on it
they drop the n yeah drop the n word
right kept magnetic resonance imager and
it's arguably the most potent tool in
the arsenal of the medical doctor to
diagnose the condition of your body
without cutting you open that is based
on a principle of physics discovered by
a physicist who had no interest in
medicine so quantum physics lasers
nuclear magnetic resonance
the list goes on
it goes another one
yeah we'll see one more okay do you know
the laser alignment that connected the
space shuttle to dock with the space
station
used a certain laser and programming
technology that was then adapted
for lasik surgery
allowing the laser to align with your
eye even if your eye moves so that the
cut is always in the right place so so
then you might say well
why have a 18 billion dollar agency just
to invent grooves in a pavement
okay
we should have the transportation safety
board invent this
but they didn't
yeah we should have other people
invented but they didn't
this is my point
however complex or however simple the
germination of an idea does not always
come because you legislated it and in
the agencies that you set up make sure
they're cross-pollinating pathways
without which people stay in their silos
of thinking and no truly great
discoveries would unfold you can't
necessarily decide to tell someone to
get an idea or to do something better
but when a better idea or a really
forward-thinking organization comes
along and happens to do it really well
spread it share it enable it
thanks for watching